[Applauso]
la resilienza è la capacità di ogni
essere umano di resistere agli urti
violenti degli ammazza sogni
sostanzialmente essere resilienti
significa trovare il coraggio di
ritornare in piedi come dico spesso a
mio figlio giuseppe
se ti fossi spaventato delle ginocchia
sbucciate non avresti mai imparato a
guidare una bicicletta e giuseppe ha
capito ha capito benissimo che cadere
non significa fallire ma imparare a
rialzarsi e l'ho capito talmente bene
che sta insegnando alla sua sorellina
andrea luna come si fa
e loro anche mi hanno fatto capire una
cosa importante esiste un unico modo per
educare alla vita ed è quello di farlo
attraverso l'esempio e io oggi sono qui
per raccontarvi il mio di esempio
attraverso il mio sogno
sì perché credo che ognuno di noi venga
al mondo con un valido motivo vivere i
propri sogni
ma il compito più difficile è anche
quello più complicato e proprio capire
come si fa
ma bisogna scegliere di farlo prendersi
la responsabilità di rischiare e
soprattutto prendersi anche la
responsabilità di commettere degli
errori perché sapete commettere degli
errori non ci rende dei falliti
no al contrario ci rende degli esperti e
soprattutto ci avvicina quanto più
possibile ai nostri sogni
è questo
e questo sapete ci rende felici ma
proprio felici dentro realizzarsi
perseguire un ideale dare una
motivazione alla nostra vita
una motivazione a prescindere a
prescindere dalle nostre condizioni
fisiche economiche sociali e soprattutto
a prescindere da tutte quelle persone
che cercano in ogni modo di dire i
nostri sogni
ecco vi ho già parlato di loro li
ammazza sogni
io non amo nelle etichette nelle
categorie ma loro è davvero utile
differenziarli li ammazzo sogni per
amore sono sostanzialmente quelle
persone che uccidono i nostri sogni per
proteggerci per tutelarci dalla
sofferenza prendono le nostre ali strat
strat ecc e le strappano via per
impedirci di volare non riuscendo a
capire che in realtà noi interessa
davvero prendere il volo
penserete ci amano non ci fanno soffrire
no al contrario perché seppur
involontariamente ci fanno perdere
fiducia in noi stessi e nelle nostre
capacità e poi noi chiamiamo ed è molto
difficile combattere contro le persone
che amiamo e allora dobbiamo cercare di
affrontarli senza ferirli dobbiamo
cercare di far capire loro la nostra
motivazione il nostro perché faccio un
esempio potremmo dire ai nostri genitori
che il nostro percorso di studi dobbiamo
essere noi a sceglierlo e che non deve
essere necessariamente il prolungamento
dell'oro oppure peggio ancora dei soldi
sogni che non sono riusciti a realizzare
oppure potremmo dire ai nostri genitori
che l'uomo la donna della nostra vita
dobbiamo essere noi a sceglierlo perché
deve piacere a noi e poi e poi ci sono
degli altri ammazza sogni li ammazza
sogni per odio
sostanzialmente sono quelle quei sogni
authority arrivati a un certo punto
della loro vita per un qualsiasi motivo
hanno deciso di arrendersi e da quel
momento in poi per giustificare la loro
pigrizia hanno deciso che distruggeranno
i suoi bisogni degli altri sono quelli
che non vedono l'ora di dirci non ci
riuscirai mai sei un fallito
oppure quando commettiamo degli errori
non ve l'avevo detto
te l'avevo detto riconosciamo tutti no
ebbene come si combattono questi ammazza
sogni abbiamo due modi per combatterli
il primo ignorandoli attraverso
l'indifferenza il secondo che un po più
complicato ma sicuramente più utile
sfidandoli tu non ti fidi di me tu non
credi ma ti dimostrerò che il contrario
utilizziamoli come trampolino di lancio
per i nostri sogni
noi li sfidiamo e poi vinciamo
ma per vincere serve conoscere l'ultimo
ammazza sogni in realtà lo conosciamo
tutti e solo che troppo spesso ci manca
il coraggio di guardarlo in faccia
sto parlando della mazza sogni che
abbiamo dentro
ma se non riusciamo ad affrontarlo
difficilmente troveranno il coraggio di
affrontare gli altri due
e allora dobbiamo ricominciare ad avere
fiducia in noi stessi dobbiamo
ricominciare a trovare energia e
apprendere l'entusiasmo nei nostri sogni
e soprattutto non dobbiamo arrenderci
perché quando gliela diamo vinta gli
ammazza sogni perdiamo noi
[Applauso]
starete pensando è facile a parole
no non lo è affatto anzi è
difficilissimo ma difficile impossibile
sono due cose diverse
e sapete col tempo imparato che non
esistono sogni impossibili solo persone
poco coraggiose e il come ognuno di noi
lo trova io ad esempio il mio come l'ho
scoperto a 24 anni quando mi è stata
diagnosticata la sclerosi multipla una
malattia che spaventa spaventato ogni
età perchè in qualsiasi momento della
tua vita
sai che tutto può cambiare
improvvisamente ea volte anche in
maniera per n
e allora in quel momento ho pensato che
faccio mi lamento e mi arrendo alla
malattia oppure oppure con coraggio vivo
i miei sogni
allora da quel giorno il mio motto è
diventato più sogni meno lagne e così
quando la terapia mi costringe a letto
al vomito alla febbre alta quando non
riesco a muovere le mie braccio le mie
gambe
ecco proprio in quel momento io sogno
sogno tantissimo ho proprio fatto una
lista di questi sogni sì li ho messi
lista anzi vi invito a farlo anche voi
mettete liste ai vostri sogni così
quando sto per arrendermi penso alla mia
lista
penso tutti i sogni che ho realizzato e
penso a tutti quelli che realizzerò che
l'ora ricordo
ricordo quando ad esempio io volevo
laurearmi e lei mi impediva di vedere
e stato allora che ho capito che avrei
dovuto ascoltare meglio per combatterla
così tra una lezione un'altra audio mi
sono laureata e poi ricordo quando
desideravo più di ogni altra cosa al
mondo di diventare madre lei la malattia
non pensava che avrei rischiato il mio
presente per il futuro si sbagliava
quando è nato giuseppe immagino la sua
faccia tre chili e mezzo di felicità e
poi ricordo quando contro tutto e tutti
desideravo che mio figlio non fosse
figlio unico ha proprio perso le staffe
quando ha visto andare
la luna la sua bellezza la accecata ha
pensato bene per due lunghissimi mesi di
impedirmi di prenderla in braccio e per
non farmi mancare nulla ha sostituito i
miei bellissimi tacchi con delle
tristissime stampelle
beh oggi io sono fiera di tenere in
braccio mia figlia che ha cinque anni e
sono fiera di essere qui su questo palco
e di parlarvi dall'alto del mio tacco 12
e poi ricordo quando mi rendeva
impossibile anche una piccola
passeggiata di 100 metri sarà rimasta di
stucco la malattia quando assieme a
centinaia di escursionisti
ho attraversato la calabria a piedi da
costa a costa e poi e poi ricordo di
quando facevo l'ingegnere e la
ndrangheta venne a bussare alla mia
porta
ricordo il coraggio di mio padre di
denunciare e poi ricordo il senso di
sconforto e di abbandono quando per un
motivo assurdo io e altre 33 persone
rimasi non senza lavoro anche lì avevo
un bivio di fronte
scegli più sogni e meno lagne decisi di
partire da me dei miei sogni
anzi addirittura dai miei bisogni di
mamma di professionista che non si ferma
un attimo è inventai una piattaforma che
commercializza cofanetti di coccole
avete capito bene esperienze emozionali
rinchiuse racchiuse dentro un cofanetto
che possano donarci un attimo di
felicità di spensieratezza
beh lei la malattia come tanti altri
squali non avrebbe scommesso nulla su di
me mi è toccata ad eluderla anche questa
volta a un'azienda che da tre anni
fattura coccole in italia e presto nel
mondo
in realtà la malattia mi ha tolto tanto
ogni giorno mi sottopone a dolore
sofferenza fatica però mi ha insegnato
una cosa mi ha insegnato il mio come
come essere resiliente perché ho capito
una cosa che se mi rialzo dopo una
brutta caduta
ho il coraggio di guardarle le mie
cicatrici mi rendo conto che il mio
valore e mi rendo conto che il nemico mi
ha resa più forte
e poi c'è un'altra cosa che voglio
condividere con voi per me la cosa più
importante
la lezione più bella che la vita mi
abbia dato il mio perché stavo
affrontando una profonda crisi
matrimoniale la mia famiglia credeva che
la mia vita da imprenditrice la mia
carriera non non fosse compatibile con
il mio ruolo di moglie e madre allora
decisi di ritornare alla mia vita
perfetta ma mediocre e ad essere solo
una moglie è solo una madre decise di
far morire i miei sogni
andai a prendere i miei figli a scuola e
giuseppe mi guardò comunque i suoi occhi
castani e indagatori mi disse mamma cosa
succede
dissi a casa vogliono che io rinuncio al
mio sogno perché pensano che il mio
lavoro tolga del tempo mi guardò con una
maturità imbarazzante per i suoi soli 5
anni e mi disse mammina tu devi farmi
una promessa
tu devi promettermi che non rinuncerà
mai al tuo sito
perché il tuo sito il tuo lavoro è il
tuo lavoro mammina è il tuo sogno
e sai che succede mammina se ognuno di
noi rinuncia anche a una sola briciolina
dei propri sogni
il mondo diventa secco
[Applauso]
e io rimasi per un attimo in silenzio e
poi dissi te lo prometto giuseppe e
quella promessa che io sono qui ed è
grazie a quella promessa che io continuo
a vivere ea lottare per i miei sogni e
continua a vivere a lottare per quello
che sono
ho capito una cosa importante sono i
bambini ad insegnarci come si diventa
grandi
ed è proprio questo il messaggio che
voglio condividere con voi
non accontentatevi di una vita mediocre
non arrendetevi agli ammazza sogni non
permettete a niente ea nessuno di
calpestarlo
i vostri sogni perché proprio come dice
giuseppe un mondo senza sogni è un mondo
secco
[Applauso]